mais je veux
retrouver ton sourire
oui je veux
trouver ton sourire et dans tes yeux
et dans tes yeux
c'est dans une ambiance détendue que le
cortège s'élance en début d'après-midi
ils sont plus de 3000 à converger vers
Saint Jean de Maurienne ville clé du
projet de ligne à grande vitesse reliant
Lyon à Turin c'est ici que le forage
d'un tunnel long de 57 km entre les
Alpes françaises et italiennes et censés
démarrer
Boudjellal qui a une légitimité pour
parler sur tous les sujets parce que il
est à la fois ingénieur des ponts et
chaussés il a fait central il a fait
Polytechnique tout donc vas-y explique
ton élève était pas en classe
il faut comprendre qu'à l'époque en 1963
c'est l'explosion de la société de
consommation le mot d'ordre de
l'hypermarché c'était tout sur le même
toit il voulait vendre des maisons des
appartements du gaz de l'électricité
avec le début de quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est critiqué et est
critiquable c'est l'explosion du tout
automobile donc l'hypermarché est né de
l'automobile également
dans la merde
[Musique]
au feu
le tout premier client de l'hypermarché
qui a été retrouvé j'étais le premier à
courir dans les années c'est immense
magasin parce qu'à l'époque on était
habitué qu'au petites épiceries et j'ai
évidemment été vers les bonbons c'était
mon âge j'ai acheté deux paquets de
chewing-gum pour le prix d'un paquet à
l'épicerie du coin mais c'était
totalement magique acclamer
[Applaudissements]
voie radulée
cet après-midi à Paris le patron de
Tesla fait le show mais pas un mot sur
sa nouvelle usine européenne très
convoitée
la France veut l'installer dans les
hauts de France mais l'Espagne mise sur
la région de Valence
c'est un exemple de réussite tout le
monde a un petit peu envie de faire
Camille on sait pas trop ce qu'il fait
mais il fait des choses intéressantes
c'est surtout ça personnalité un peu
décalée sa manière de Twitter le Stade
de France quand même
facile
France si on séduction
nouvelle rencontre aujourd'hui entre
Emmanuel Macron et Elon Musk la
troisième en six mois
l'enjeu est de taille la Tesla Model y
est aujourd'hui la voiture neuve la plus
vendue dans le monde Joe Biden qui
ordonnait la publication du rapport de
la CIA et qui avait promis durant sa
campagne de ne plus lui adresser la
parole a tenu moins de deux ans
l'expéria a eu droit à un check du
président américain en juillet dernier à
Jeddah et dans la foulée Emmanuel Macron
a été le premier dirigeant européen à le
recevoir à nouveau
du corps tu inspires et puis en expirant
tu dis ben je m'en fous je m'en fous je
m'en fous ça va libérer un peu ces
émotions
je mets mon tablier mon torchon et je
suis en cuisine
tu l'as Olivier
il en a clairement rien à faire de ce
que je lui dis une confirmation les
Toulousains ont définitivement le sens
de la fête ils ont célébré leur 22e
titre de champion de France de rugby
après leur victoire en finale Top 14
contre La Rochelle la ville rose a
accueilli ces héros vous le voyez et le
Bouclier de Brennus cet après-midi et
puis cette image très partagée
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
celle d'Emmanuel Macron venu salut et
les joueurs dans le vestiaire après leur
victoire et qui sous les encouragements
à but d'une traite d'une bouteille
entière de bière cul sec selon
l'expression consacrée même si quel que
soit le contexte vous le savez il faut
boire avec modération on est d'accord
Vincent que c'est pas toujours facile
d'évaluer sa consommation comment on
sait si on est dans les clous c'est vrai
que c'est pas simple parce qu'on
pourrait se dire je sais
l'idéal serait quand même de tenir un
petit calepin voilà c'est vrai ou alors
sur votre téléphone je sais bien je suis
ravages
excusez-moi est-ce que l'alcool les
résumé de votre vie quand même parce que
j'ai l'impression que entre l'histoire
de Cannes ou alors Julien qu'est-ce
qu'on ferait pour s'amuser c'est pas un
apéro mais on avait dit un weekend
entier plusieurs apéros
fais gaffe ça va m'en vouloir là Julien
comme c'est la fête des pères et qu'on a
tous cultivé en tant qu'enfant le jardin
intérieur et bien
bonne fête des papas à tous les papas
alors
cruelle a quelle heure phrase précédente
pour l'aider à trouver ces 6 mots
manquant la vodka qui brûle un peu la
gorge mais qui nous arrêtez d'embêter
les filles avec ça franchement
si je gagne je crois que je vais me
payer une queue rentre des symptômes
jusqu'au jour où sa fille de 9 ans
provoque
électrochocs et me défoncer tous les
jours et puis je me suis fait choper
avec ma grande quoi quand elle était
petite et c'est et voilà et du coup ça a
été ça a été celle des clic quoi
est-ce que tu te rends pas
est-ce que tu dors papa
j'ai chanté une fois j'ai enregistré une
chanson pour l'homme que j'aime voilà
François Hollande on fait tourner
chez moi non
toujours pas vous avez vu quelque chose
moi j'ai rien vu faut pas le faire à
poil ça et curieusement maintenant que
la boutique est fermée c'est terminé on
en parle plus et ben c'est vrai
curieusement vous voyez maintenant il y
a une espèce de une nouvelle génération
de jeunes gens qui sont très attirés par
les femmes plus âgées bon ça peut
s'appeler aussi gérontophilie
hier elle a rencontré un canasson et
elle a pris au pied de la lettre
l'expression avoir une haleine de cheval
bah tiens mon petit gars
je veux
revoir le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ciel
[Musique]